ces relais lucien et stéphanie chercher
barthelme y ont de quoi sourire
le gouvernement fédéral annoncera sous
peu programme spécial temporaire pour
régulariser le statut de demandeur
d'asile travailleurs essentiel de la
santé comme elle au gouvernement les
deux préposés aux bénéficiaires qui ont
contracté lakovic 19 sont soulagés
c'est une signe de gratitude envers non
parce que l autre sauf qu'on a beaucoup
travaillé parce que la virus est
contagieux et ses dangers on les skates
tout le programme viserait tous les
employés du milieu de la santé comme les
préposés aux bénéficiaires
les préposés à l'entretien et les agents
de sécurité pour y être admissible il
faudra être demandeur d'asile détenir un
permis de travail valide avoir travaillé
au moins quatre semaines dans le domaine
de la santé depuis le 25 janvier et
avoir fait une demande d'asile
avant l'annoncé du programme aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est l'accomplissement de
de l'école de l'ouverture de la
solidarité fidi fait que tout le monde
s'est mis ensemble pour dire qu'il
fallait trouver une façon de remercier
ces gens là pour leur travail
exceptionnelle dans une situation
exceptionnelle des groupes
communautaires comme la maison d'haïti
ont fait pression sur les gouvernements
pour la mise en place d'une telle mesure
on est d'autant plus content qu'on l'a
obtenu sa pour les personnes qui
travaillent au secteur de la santé au
québec mais pour le reste des personnes
qui travaillent au canada aussi dans la
même situation à québec comme à ottawa
presque tous les partis d'opposition
demandait aussi la régularisation du
statut de ces migrants on est très
content que le gouvernement se rende aux
demandes de la société civile qui est
aux motions qui avaient été déposées par
le bloc auquel malheureusement les
conservateurs s'étaient opposés les
défenseurs des droits des migrants
demande au gouvernement fédéral de ne
pas laisser de côté les autres
travailleurs essentiel migrants comme
ceux du secteur de l'alimentation
parce que disent ils c'est aussi grâce à
eux que le pays peut faire face à la
crise ici valérie michael abeilles radio
canada montréal